indignación en Alemania e Israel después
de que el jefe de la autoridad Palestina
más mudabas comparará la política
israelí hacia los palestinos con el
genocidio de los judíos por parte de la
Alemania nazi
desde 1947 hasta hoy Israel ha cometido
50 masacres en 50 ciudades palestinas 50
masacres 50 holocaustos Y todavía hoy
Hay muertos todos los días por culpa del
ejército israelí el canciar Alemán
reaccionó al día siguiente a las
declaraciones de habas estoy
profundamente indignado por la
sincalificables declaraciones del
presidente palestino magmurabás para
nosotros los alemanes en particular
cualquier relativización del holocausto
es intolerable e inaceptable
fue criticado por la oposición por no
reaccionar inmediatamente en la
conferencia a las declaraciones de ambas
que provocaron también un fuerte rechazo
por parte del Primer Ministro israelí
acuse a Israel de haber o cometido 50
holocaustos mientras está en suelo
alemán no solo es una vergüenza moral
sino una mentira monstruosa 6 millones
de judíos fueron asesinados en el
holocausto incluyendo un millón y medio
de niños judíos la historia nunca lo
perdonará la oficina declaró que sus
comentarios no pretendían negar la
singularidad del holocausto pero
recordar al mundo que lo perdiera de
vista las masacres infligidas al pueblo
palestino desde 1967 Israel ocupa
ilegalmente cisjordania impuso un
bloqueo agasa en 2007 sus acciones son a
regularmente denunciadas por la
comunidad internacional como crímenes de
guerra